is a firewall. And obviously the word firewall is coming from something that can stop fires
from spreading into different areas. And so that's how it works.
In this section we're going to discuss firewalls and what's important to understand from your
perspective.
perspective is the difference between firewall technologies and firewall architectures. In
this section we're going to talk firewall technologies. If you look at the word technologies
it really means how a firewall can make decisions. But before we get into that let's define the
word firewall itself. What is a firewall? And obviously the word firewall is coming from
something that can stop fires from spreading into different areas. And so that's how the
term got to be. But in network security a firewall either allows or blocks traffic based
on predefined rules. And so that's what a firewall is. You want a place of firewall in between
two networks so that you protect them from each other. And the concept of a firewall
is something that is very important in network security. And not only do we want to place
firewalls to protect our network from the outside. But in some cases you also want firewalls
on the inside of the network to protect different network segments from each other. So a firewall
is not a device, it's not a appliance. It's simply a concept. It can be as simple as a router
for example that simply makes decisions. Or it can be as sophisticated as a large set
of applications that are doing things like deep packet inspection and web content filtering
and intrusion detection and anti-malware. So the word firewall itself simply means any
technology, any ability to be able to either allow or what we deny into certain segments
or networks for example. And so if you look at the different technologies that are available
for us to be able to make those types of decisions, there are really only three firewall technologies
that exist. And they are represented here on this slide. So the three technologies and that's
the key word that you want to look for is the word technology itself. We have simple packet
filtering. We have stateful packet filtering technologies. And we also have what are called
proxy firewalls. So let's look at each of these in a little bit of detail. Packet filtering
simply means a router for example that operates at layer three. And the only decision that
this type of firewall technology can make is based on what layer three can only understand.
And so if you remember to what we discussed, as you go up in the OSI model, you gain more
intelligence. You have more functionality for example, but you lose efficiency and speed.
So packet filtering firewalls operate at layer three, which means they are still pretty
efficient, but they are limited in the decisions that they can make. And so this can be represented
by a simple router that makes decisions based on what it can understand in the header portion
of the datagram for example. So simple decisions like based on source IP address and destination
IP address, the type of packet that it is, the service that's being requested for example,
are the very simple decisions that a packet filtering type of firewall can make at layer
three. Now we also have what are called stateful packet filtering firewalls. They only
still operate at layer three, but the advantage that they have is that they have the ability
to keep historical information about outgoing requests that can be stored for example in
what we call dynamic state tables. So we store state and context information in these dynamic
state tables so that when the request comes back, let's say a second later, we can use
what we've kept in those tables to make a more informed decision. The idea is, let's
say you originate a outgoing request out to the web or to the internet. The stateful packet
filtering firewall would keep information about that outgoing request, such as it came
from your machine or your IP address. It's a UDP request and it went out at nine o'clock
in the morning, let's say. So that information is kept in that dynamic state table so that
when the request comes back a second later, the firewall can say, okay, the disrequest
just go out previous to it. Is it destined for the same machine that originated it? And
is it a UDP request? And if the answer to all of those questions are yes, then the firewall
would allow that traffic back into the internal network. But if the answer to any of those
questions or no, then the firewall can say, I'm not going to let this in and just drop
that traffic basically. So the idea of stateful inspection firewalls is we can keep state
and context information, historical information in these tables that can allow us to make
a more informed decision as that request comes back. The third type of firewall technology
is what we call proxy firewalls. And these operate at the higher layers of the OSI model
and as such, they are able to make more informed decisions, right? So the key word here is
proxy. And if you look up the word proxy in a dictionary, it's going to say acting on
behalf of someone else. So the idea is as a request comes in from the outside internet,
we redirect that decision to a specific application that has been built to make a more informed
decision. And the difference between circuit level proxy firewalls and application level proxy
firewalls is that the layer that they operate at. So for example, circuit level proxy firewalls
operate at layer five, the session layer. And the way that they work is they simply establish
a connection if you've provided the right level of information. For example, you've put
in the right credential information such as your user ID, your password, and possibly
a two factor authentication number, for example. And if the answers to those are yes, then
the session layer circuit level proxy firewall would allow a session to be established through
your VPN connection, for example. The other type of proxy firewall is application proxy firewalls.
They operate at layer seven. And because they operate at layer seven, they are the most
functional, the most intelligent. We can create applications that operate at this layer that
can make any sort of decision that you want. So these ones can be programmed to make decisions
based on things like web content filtering. We can do anti malware. We can do intrusion
detection. We can make all kinds of decisions because we can add that functionality at
layer seven through any sort of firewall, for example, or application that is built specifically
to do that. So these are firewall technologies. In other words, they allow us to make decisions.
And the difference between all of them is the layer that they operate at according to
the OSI model. So anything that you do a layer three, for example, which means simple packet
filtering and stateful can only involve decisions that are understood at that layer.
Proxy firewalls, because they operate at higher layers, are able to make better decisions.
And so companies need to formulate these and obviously put them together so that we make
the decisions that we need to as far as what traffic is coming into the organization itself.
So here on this slide, we've got some examples. And basically what we're talking about here
is the difference between simple packet filtering and stateful packet filtering. And like
we explained before, the simple difference is that simple packet filtering firewalls
that can be like a simple router that makes decisions based on the header portion of the
datagram is not able to keep historical information to be able to make better decisions.
So the only decisions that can be made here are the ones that exist in that specific header
portion of the datagram itself. Again, decisions related to source IP address, destination IP
address, and so on. Now obviously, the stateful inspection firewalls are able to make better
decisions because they are able to keep that state and context information about outgoing
request that can be kept so that when the request comes back, we can make a more informed
decision. And so this is a summary slide of the different technologies that we can use
in order to be able to make decisions as a firewall. Again, we call these firewall technologies.
So simple packet filtering operates at layer three. They are the simplest type of firewall,
but they are also the fastest and the most efficient because they operate natively at
layer three. Then we have what are called stateful packet filtering. They also operate at
layer three, but because they are able to keep historical information about outgoing requests,
they are a little more intelligent, but they still are efficient and only able to make
decisions at layer three. Now, our proxy firewalls are the ones that provide the most intelligence.
And again, the difference between level five and level seven or circuit level and application
level is that circuit level simply establish a session if the right information is provided,
whereas application proxy firewalls are able to do a whole bunch of intelligent decisions
because they are able to interpret the data portion of the data gram and keep historical
information and make any decision that we really need to do at that point.